♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
MARSHA BLACKBURN OF TENNESSEE
ASKED BIDEN'S SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE, KETANJI JACKSON, WHAT
SHOULD BE THE EASIEST QUESTION
POSED.
CAN YOU DEFINE WHAT A WOMAN IS?
PUT YOURSELF IN YOUR POSITION
AND HOW RELIEVED JACKSON MUST'VE
BEEN WHEN SHE HEARD THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE SHE STAYED UP
ALL NIGHT MEMORIZING UP TO YOUR
CASE LAW FROM 1970 AND COURT
PRESIDENT.
WHEN SHE FINALLY GETS TO HEARING
THEM, ALL THE REPUBLICANS WANT
IS A RECAP OF NINTH GRADE
BIOLOGY.
WHAT IS A WOMAN?
A WORLD FAMOUS SCHOLAR LIKE
KETANJI JACKSON, THAT SHOULD BE
SLOW AND STEADY DOWN THE PLATE.
A WOMAN, JACKSON WOULD'VE SAID
LOOKING INCREDULOUS?
THAT SIMPLE.
A WOMAN IS A HUMAN BEING WITH 2X
CHROMOSOMES.
ASK ANY GENETICIST.
IF YOU'RE STILL CONFUSED BY WHAT
A WOMAN IS, YOU CAN ASK A
DOCTOR.
WOMEN HAVE WIDER PELVIS IS AN
DIFFERENT BONE STRUCTURES FROM
MEN, NOT TO MENTION DIFFERENT.
IT'S OBVIOUS TO WOMEN LOOKING AT
THEM.
WOMEN ARE BUILT DIFFERENTLY
BECAUSE THEIR BODIES ARE
DESIGNED TO DO DIFFERENT THINGS.
NATURE IS REAL.
WOMEN AND MEN STRAIGHT.
WOMEN GIVE BIRTH AND BREASTFEED.
MEN DO NOT DO THESE THINGS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T.
NOT A SINGLE MAN IN ALL HUMAN
HISTORY HAS EVER HAD HIS PERIOD
OR DELIVERED A BABY AND I
NOTICED, SENATOR, BECAUSE I'M A
WOMAN MYSELF.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
BIDEN NOMINATED ME BECAUSE I AM
FEMALE AND SAID SO HIMSELF MANY
TIMES.
THE PRESIDENT KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT
HE WOMAN IS.
IF HE DIDN'T KNOW, HE WOULDN'T
HAVE PICKED ME, OBVIOUSLY.
PLEASE, SENATOR BLACKBURN, DO
NOT WASTE MY TIME.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, THAT'S AN
INCREDIBLY STUPID QUESTION.
IMAGINE IF SHE SAID THAT.
WHAT AN ANSWER THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN.
DO YOU KNOW A SINGLE PERSON WHO
WOULDN'T HAVE CHEERED?
HONESTY IS A WONDERFUL THING THE
WATCH NO MATTER WHERE IT COMES
FROM.
BUT THAT IS NOT WHAT KETANJI
JACKSON SAID.
HERE IS ACTUAL ANSWER.
>> CAN YOU PROVIDE A DEFINITION
FOR THE WORD WOMAN?
>> CAN I PROVIDE A DEFINITION?
YEAH.
I CAN'T.
>> YOU CAN'T?
>> NOT IN THIS CONTEXT.
I'M NOT A BIOLOGIST.
>> Tucker: "I'M NOT A
BIOLOGIST."
YOU FOLLOW THIS?
ONLY A BIOLOGIST CAN TELL YOU
WHAT A WOMAN IS AND KETANJI
JACKSON, AS OPPRESSIVE AS SHE
IS, REMINDED US SHE IS NOT A
BIOLOGIST.
NOBODY IN THE PARTY CARES ABOUT
WHAT BIOLOGY IS, BIOLOGICAL SEX.
ALSO THE WOMAN WHO WROTE THE
HARRY POTTER NOVELS.
PROBLEM IN THE FACE OF THE TRANS
LOBBY.
ACADEMIC CREDENTIALS NOT
SPEAKING ALL THAT RELEVANT HERE.
BUT STILL.
PAUSE FOR A SECOND AND MARINATE
IN THE AWE-INSPIRING STUPIDITY
OF HER ANSWER.
WHAT'S A WOMAN?
I DON'T KNOW.
I'M NOT A BIOLOGIST.
I SEE HOW THIS WORKS.
HEY, KETANJI JACKSON, IS IT
RAINING.
I DON'T KNOW, I'M NOT A
METEOROLOGIST.
HOW WOULD YOU RESPOND TO SOMEONE
WHO SPEAKS LIKE THAT?
THAT PERSON IS NOT POSSIBLE OF
CONVERSATION.
LAST NIGHT WE SAID WE WANTED TO
SEE KETANJI JACKSON'S L
LSAT SCORES BUT WE CAN SAY SHE'S
A SUB GENIUS AND SHOULDN'T BE ON
THE SUPREME COURT.
WHAT'S A WOMAN?
THE MOST REVEALING QUESTION
NEVER ASKED IN A SENATE
CONFIRMATION HEARING AND ONE OF
THE MANY THINGS IT REVEALS IS
HOW UTTERLY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S INSTITUTION
HAS CHANGED IN JUST FOUR YEARS.
IT'S A MILE MARKER THAT TELLS US
THE EVOLUTION OF THIS PARTY.
DURING THE LAST SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION, YOU REMEMBER, WE
WERE COMMANDED TO BELIEVE THAT
ALL WOMEN MUST BE BELIEVED
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WERE TELLING THE TRUTH.
THEY ARE WOMEN.
THEREFORE IN THE NAME OF SOCIAL
JUSTICE YOU MUST ACCEPT WHATEVER
THEY SAY AT FACE VALUE.
A WOMAN'S WORD IS LIKE A SWORN
AFFIDAVIT.
YOU CAN TAKE IT TO THE BANK.
HERE'S KAMALA HARRIS TO EXPLAIN.
>> LET'S SPEAK THE TRUTH ABOUT
WHAT WE'VE ALL BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THE LAST FEW DAYS AND
AGAIN THIS EVENING, WHICH IS THE
SUPREME COURT PROCESS.
LET'S SPEAK THE TRUTH.
IT WAS A SHAM.
[APPLAUSE]
AND A DISGRACE.
LET'S SPEAK THE TRUTH.
IT WAS A DENIAL OF JUSTICE FOR
THE WOMEN OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: HOW AMUSING IS IT
TO SEE YOU KAMALA HARRIS SAY,
LET'S SPEAK THE TRUTH!
THROW YOUR BEER CAN AT THE TV IF
YOU AGREE.
IN 2019, IT WAS "A SHAM AND A
DISGRACE" TO SHAME A WOMAN'S
WORD BY THE VIRTUE OF THEIR
BIOLOGY, WOMEN DO NOT LIE.
THAT'S WHAT IT MEANS TO BE A
WOMAN.
UTTERLY TRUTHFUL ALL THE TIME.
BIDEN AGREED WITH THIS.
WOMEN WERE VERY DIFFERENT FROM
MEN.
INHERENTLY.
HE TOLD US SO.
THAT'S WHY YOU WEREN'T ALLOWED
TO HIT THEM.
WATCH.
>> WE FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
CULTURE OF HOW WOMEN ARE
TREATED.
NO MAN HAS A RIGHT TO RAISE A
HAND TO A WOMAN IN ANGER OTHER
THAN IN SELF-DEFENSE, AND THAT
RARELY EVER OCCURS.
WE JUST HAVE TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE PERIOD.
KEEP PUNCHING AT IT AND PUNCHING
NIGHT AND PUNCHING THAT IT.
>> Tucker: WE MOCKED HIM.
"KEEP PUNCHING AT IT!"
WE MADE FUN OF HIM BUT HE WAS
ONTO SOMETHING.
WHAT HE SAID WAS ENTIRELY TRUE.
TWO MEN GET INTO A BAR FIGHT.
THE OTHER PLEASURES THE ONES IN
THE FACE.
WHAT YOU RESPONSE?
TAKE IT OUTSIDE.
A MAN AND A WOMAN GET IN A BAR
FIGHT, THE MAN PUNCHES A WOMAN
IN THE FACE, YOUR RESPONSE THAT?
IF YOU ARE A NORMAL HUMAN BEING,
YOU ARE HORRIFIED.
NOT JUST A FELONY, THOUGH IT IS,
IT IS A MORAL CRIME.
DECENT PEOPLE DON'T PUNCH WOMEN
IN THE FACE PERIOD.
A MAN'S BEST INSTINCT IS TO
PROTECT WOMEN.
THAT'S NOTHING TO BE ASHAMED OF.
IT MAKES CIVILIZATION CIVILIZED.
THAT'S WHY WE DON'T SEND
EXPECTANT MOTHERS INTO BATTLE.
PREGNANT FLIGHT SUITS ARE AN
ATTEMPT TO DENY OUR MOST BASIC
INSTINCTS, AND INSTINCT WE
SHOULD NOT BE ASHAMED OF.
JOE BIDEN HAS THIS INSTINCT.
HE NOTED IT.
HE WAS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
MEN AND WOMEN ARE NOT THE SAME.
ONE IS NOT MORALLY BETTER THAN
OTHER, THEY ARE MORALLY EQUAL
BUT THEY ARE DIFFERENT ON
BIOLOGY.
WE ARE BORN KNOWING IT.
THEY ARE NOW COMMENDING YOU TO
PRETEND OTHERWISE, TO DENY
NATURE AND SUPPRESS YOUR MOST
BASIC NATURE, AND VALUABLE
INSTINCT.
THEY TELL YOU YOU HAVE NO RIGHT
TO BE MORE UPSET WHEN WOMAN IS
INJURED.
WHEN A WOMAN GETS HER EAR BITTEN
OFF IN A BAR FIGHT MORE THAN A
MAN DOES.
ARE YOU READY TO SUPPRESS THIS
INSTANCE?
AS A SOCIETY THAT WON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THEM?
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE JUDGMENT
SYSTEM IF MEN AND WOMEN ARE THE
SAME OR DON'T EXIST?
IF KETANJI JACKSON CAN SAY WHO
WAS A MAN WHO WAS A WOMAN WILL
CHANGE HOW WE ADMINISTER JUSTICE
FOLLOWING WITH OUR
ANTIDISCRIMINATION LAWS.
IF WE CAN'T SAY FOR CERTAIN WHO
IS A WOMAN, HOW ARE WE GOING TO
ENFORCE JOE BIDEN'S PAINLESS
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN ACT.
WHY WOULD WE HAVE SUCH AN ACT?
HOW DO WE SET ASIDE A HUGE
PERCENTAGE OF FEDERAL CONTRACTS
FOR WOMEN-OWNED COMPANIES IF WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT A WOMAN IS.
I GUESS THAT SCAM IS GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE TO END TOMORROW
BECAUSE IT'S NOT GOING TO MAKE
ANY SENSE.
HOW IS SEXISM IN A MEANINGFUL
CATEGORY IN A WORLD IN WHICH SEX
HAS NO MEANING?
WHY HAVE TITLE IX?
IF WE HAVE NO BIOLOGICAL SEX,
HOW CAN WE HAVE DISCRIMINATION
ON THE BASIS OF BIOLOGICAL SEX.
THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE TRIED TO
PRESERVE TITLE IX BY ARGUING ON
THE CONCEPT AS DEFINED IN THAT
LAW THAT ARRIVES -- AS BIOLOGY,
NOT HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT YOUR
PERSONAL IDENTITY ON ANY
PARTICULAR DAY.
THEY WERE DENOUNCED AS A RIGHT
WING LUNATICS FOR THE ACLU
DECLARED A QUOTE, "THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS TRYING TO
ERASE TRANS PEOPLE."
MAYBE IT WAS BIGGER THAN THAT.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TOOK
CHARGE OF EVERYTHING AND IN LESS
THAN A YEAR, THE WORST MOST
FERVENT PREDICTIONS HAVE COME
ENTIRELY TRUE.
FEMA ATHLETES ARE LOSING NCAA
CHAMPIONSHIPS TO MEN DRESSING UP
AS WOMEN IN ORDER TO CHEAT THEIR
WAY INTO VICTORY.
EVERY PERSON IN AMERICA SEE THIS
HAPPENING.
VERY FEW ARE BRAVE ENOUGH TO SAY
A WORD ABOUT IT.
BUT HERE'S ONE OF THEM.
A WOMAN WHO HAPPENED TO BE
WATCHING AN NCAA CHAMPIONSHIP IN
WHICH A MALE SWIMMER GOING BY
THE NAME OF LEAH THOMAS
DOMINATED EVERY WOMAN IN THE
POOL.
>> THAT IS NOT A WOMAN.
MY GOD.
I KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE TO HAVE HER
ON.
I'M NOT A VET BUT I KNOW WHAT A
DOG IS.
YES YOU DO.
WE ALL DO.
EVEN KETANJI JACKSON KNOWS.
SHE'S HAD A FEW CHILDREN OF OUR
OWN.
PROBABLY LEARNED HOW THE PROCESS
WORKS.
THE POINT OF THE TRANS MOVEMENT
ISN'T TO CONVINCE ANYONE THAT
BIOLOGY ISN'T REAL.
THAT'S AN IMPOSSIBLE CASE TO
MAKE.
BUT YOU WOULD SOUND RIDICULOUS
IF YOU TRIED TO ARTICULATE THAT,
MUCH LESS EXPLAIN IT.
THE POINT OF THIS EXERCISE IS
VERY DIFFERENT.
THE POINT IS TO MAKE THE REST OF
US REPEAT ALIVE.
TO SAY SOMETHING THAT WE KNOW
PERFECTLY WELL IS NOT TRUE.
LEAH THOMAS IS A PROUD BEAUTIFUL
WOMAN WHO WON THE SWIM MEET
BECAUSE SHE PRACTICED HARDER
THAN THE OTHER GIRLS.
LEAH THOMAS DESERVED TO WIN THAT
GREATER VICTORY WASN'T CHEATING
AND I DON'T NOTICE HER BULGING
SWIMSUIT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY DEMAND YOU SAY.
NOT BECAUSE THEY CARE ABOUT LEAH
THOMAS OR ANY OTHER TRANS
PERSON.
THEY COULD CARE LESS.
MAKING YOU PRETEND DIDN'T
BELIEVE SOMETHING YOU DON'T,
THAT'S THE POINT.
BECAUSE IF THEY CAN MAKE YOU TO
PRETEND TO BELIEVE SOMETHING YOU
KNOW IS UNTRUE, THEY HAVE WON.
THEY CONTROL YOUR BRAIN.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT TRANS PEOPLE.
IT'S ABOUT ALL OF US.
AND THE STAKES ARE VERY HIGH.
THAT'S WHY THIS CENSORSHIP IS SO
INTENSE BUT HAVE YOU NOTICED?
OUR NATIONAL CONVERSATION ABOUT
TRANSGENDER IS HIM IS COMPLETELY
DEFINED BY CENSORSHIP, BY MAKING
YOU SHUT UP YOU'RE NOT ALLOWING
YOU TO NOTICE THE OBVIOUS IS WHY
THEY ARE DOING IT.
THERE IS NO ATTEMPT TO PERSUADE
YOU, THERE IS NO FACT-BASED
ARGUMENT.
YOU CAN'T RESPOND, OH, SO MEN
BECAME WOMEN BY WASHING IT?
CAN I STOP MALE PATTERN BALDNESS
THE SAME WAY?
CAN I GROW 6 INCHES?
EXPLAIN HOW THIS REMARKABLE NEW
POWER THE TRANS IMMUNITY HAS
DISCOVERED MIGHT APPLY TO ME.
CAN I DO IT TOO?
THE POWER OF POSITIVE THINKING!
THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION.
THEY'LL NEVER ANSWER IT.
THEY'LL JUST MAKE YOU BE QUIET.
THEIR FIRST MOVE ALWAYS IS
CENSORSHIP AND THE SECOND MOVE
INEVITABLY IS TO BE PUNISHMENT.
WE LEARNED THAT WHEN WERE
SUSPENDED FROM TWITTER.
"WE DETERMINE THIS ACCOUNT
VIOLATED THE TWITTER RULES,
SPECIFICALLY FOR VIOLATING RULES
AGAINST HEAT FOLK
CONDUCT."
THE ONLY WAY OUT IS TO DELETE
OUR TWEET, TO PRETEND WE NEVER
SAID IT, TO CLEANSE AMERICA'S
CONSCIENCE BY JUST WIPING OUT
THE PAST.
WHAT WAS OUR CRIME BY THE WAY?
WE DARE TO HIGHLIGHT TWO
ACCOUNTS THAT TWITTER HAS
BANNED.
CHARLIE KIRK AND THE BABYLON B.
NOTHING HATEFUL ABOUT EITHER
ONE.
I'D SAY LOOK THEM UP BUT YOU
CAN'T.
I NOTICED THAT BIOLOGICAL SEX IS
FIXED AT BIRTH.
JUST ACKNOWLEDGED FOR AT LEAST
300,000 YEARS.
WHAT WAS A FACTUAL STATEMENT.
ON TWITTER, AS OUR PUBLIC LIFE,
TRUTH IS NO DEFENSE.
TWITTER IS NOW RUN BY A MAN
NAMED BROCK OUT A WHILE WHO SAID
PLAINLY THAT HE DOES NOT BELIEVE
IN FREE SPEECH B HE CAME
CONTROLS THE SINGLE MOST FORUM
FOR AMERICA'S POLITICAL
CONVERSATIONS.
THAT IS A BIG AND IMPORTANT JOB.
IT'S A KIND OF PUBLIC TRUST THAT
ALLOWS DEMOCRACY TO FUNCTION.
YOU THINK YOU'D WANT A GUY TO
HAVE SOME RESPECT FOR HIS
ADOPTED COUNTRY'S CORE
INSTITUTIONS BEGINNING WITH AND
PRIMARILY THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
EVERYONE HAS NO RESPECT FOR OUR
FIRST AMENDMENT, EXPLAINED THAT
OPENLY IN A 2020 SPEECH.
WATCH.
>> ALL WE ARE DOING IS TO NOT
BE -- OUR ROLE IS TO HELP
COMMUNICATION AND OUR MOVE
REFLECTIVE THAT WE BELIEVE TO
HELP PEOPLE HAVE A GOOD
CONVERSATION.
THE THINGS WE DO IS FOCUS LESS
ON FREE SPEECH BUT THINKING
ABOUT HOW THE DYNAMICS HAVE
CHANGED.
ONE OF THE CHANGES WE SEE TODAY
IS SPEECH IS EASY ON THE
INTERNET.
MOST PEOPLE CAN SPEAK.
WHAT WE PARTICULAR EXERCISES WHO
WHO CAN BE HEARD.
>> Tucker: THE NEW STANDARD
ISN'T YOUR RIGHT AS A CITIZEN TO
SAY WHAT YOU BELIEVE IS TRUE.
THE NEW STANDARD IS ACHIEVING
SOMETHING CALLED "HEALTHY PUBLIC
CONVERSATION."
THIS ISN'T ONE MAN'S OPINION.
YOU GREW UP IN A COUNTRY WHERE
PEOPLE ARE FREE TO SAY WHAT THEY
WANTED.
BUT NOW POLITICAL SPEECH, ALL
SPEECH HAS DISSEMINATED TO OTHER
CITIZENS VIA SOCIAL MEDIA, THIS
IS THE GUY WHO ACTUALLY CONTROLS
WHAT YOU ARE ALLOWED TO THINK.
SO WHAT IS HEALTHY PUBLIC
CONVERSATION?
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN EXACTLY?
WE ARE INTERESTED.
WE TEXTED THE VERY FIRST THING
THIS MORNING, HIS EMAIL.
IT WAS TOO COWARDLY TO RESPOND
TO US.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO ASSUME
THAT A HEALTHY PUBLIC
CONVERSATION IS WHATEVER PARADE
OUTER
WANTEDTO BE.
A SINGLE MAN WHO HAS TOTAL AND
UNDISGUISED CONTEMPT FOR
AMERICA'S MOST BASIC VALUES
AGAINST HIS DECIDE WHAT
AMERICANS DECIDE ABOUT.
HE DOESN'T THINK YOU SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO DISCUSS BASIC BIOLOGY
IN PUBLIC, OR ERASING ALL SIGNS.
SO YOU ARE NOW NOT ALLOWED TO
TALK ABOUT IT.
YOU ARE BANNED.
CENSORED.
WE CAN'T CONTROL PARAG AGRAWAL
NOT LONG AGO, THIS WAS A FREE
COUNTRY, AND PARAG AGRAWAL AND
FIVE OF THE BILLIONAIRES YOU
DON'T KNOW, THEY GET IN WITHOUT
AN ELECTION.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE THINGS WE
USED TO HAVE IN AMERICA?
THEY DON'T SEEM TO BE FIGHTING
THE POWER ANYMORE, THEY SEEM TO
HAVE JOINED IT.
HOW ABOUT LIZ CHENEY AND
ADAM KINZINGER AND EVERYBODY
ELSE LECTURING THE SERFS ABOUT
DEMOCRACY.
IS THIS THE KIND OF DEMOCRACY
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT?
A DOCTOR MIGHT
THEY'LL MAKE DEMOCRACYWERE A FE?
SOUNDS LIKE OLIGARCHY, DON'T YOU
THINK?
LET US KNOW.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE ARE WELCOME ON
THIS SHOW ANY TIM